i'm keen of course to get to those local
election results but i just want to
start off with what's happening in
northern ireland because it does feel
like quite an astonishing uh story shin
fein winning that historic victory
sending their first minister to the
northern ireland assembly what's your
reaction
well look at there is a
clearly some change in northern ireland
i think above all what we want to see is
the uk government is some stability i
think for the people of northern ireland
whichever way they voted
we want to see
an executive form the parties to come
together to provide the people of
northern ireland with that stability i
think it's equally clear that that
stability uh is being put at risk
imperiled if you like by the problems
with northern ireland protocol that's
something that affects communities
across the board and it it's clear from
the dynamic we now see that we won't get
to that position of stability until and
unless it's fixed and so we're focused
on those two elements bringing the
parties together stability but also
unlocking the problems with northern
ireland protocol unlocking the problems
with the northern ireland protocol you
sound as if this is a something that
you've got no control over this northern
ireland protocol was what you imposed
well
if it had been
implemented with the kind of flexibility
goodwill and with the
the business interests of communities
across northern ireland and it hadn't
been used frankly as a political device
in the way that that it has
i don't think we'd have the same level
of problems but the the point of
discussing that has passed we must see
it now fixed the government is committed
to fixing it and we won't get the
stability that i talked about the
political stability and that's clear as
a result of the outcome of the elections
in northern ireland it's very clear
isn't it the dep leader has uh said that
effectively they are not going to
they'll collapse power sharing they
won't form part of the
executive until the uk government deals
with the protocol this is what jeffrey
donaldson said the protocol is harming
our political process it is undermining
political stability i made clear during
this election that the government needs
to sort that out and until they do i
will not be nominating a minister to the
executive i just want to sort of pause
and reflect on how serious that is you
know the executive can't function
otherwise
a cost of living crisis well it hasn't
been an executive for some time as you
you know sophie so we want to see an
executive up and running we want to see
the parties come together in the kind of
corporation that can make that happen so
when you look at the protocol
in the queen speech i just want to get a
bit of a timeline on this the queen's
speech next week is the protocol going
to be looked at then well you know that
i can't reveal details of the queen's
speech in advance but what i would say
is first of all we want to see an
executive that can serve the people of
northern ireland the bread and butter
issues of which of course during the
local elections in northern ireland many
people have been voting on as well as uh
other issues um but it's clear the
northern ireland protocol must be fixed
the foreign secretary's talked about it
the prime minister's talked about it and
that cannot be put off because we won't
get the stability that we want we won't
get the executive that the people of
northern ireland need until it is dealt
with so how are you going to deal with
it
well look at the
preferably by negotiation but if not
we'll have to take the measures uh to
make sure that the
economic integrity of the trade between
northern ireland and the rest of great
britain and frankly the constitutional
integrity uh of the united kingdom is
protected and preserved and we've talked
about that we set out a series of
measures so this isn't a new conundrum
or problem uh brandon lewis and the
prime minister set out in a command
paper the kinds of things that we would
need to see happen
but we will deal with the situation we
will take whatever measures are
necessary to protect as i said the
economic as well as the constitutional
integrity of northern ireland but
fundamentally that northern ireland
protocol is not working for communities
right across the piece in northern
ireland and you hear
that from the businesses and from
communities across the political
spectrum so it does need to be fixed so
you do it unilaterally without the eu if
necessary oh we've been clear that that
option has not been taken off the table
we prefer to get it resolved through
negotiation that's why
we've been through a protracted period
to try and get it fixed through
negotiation but of course as you know
there are measures that we can take um
to make sure that we deal with the
problem we can't put it off and it's
clear now and in fact if anything the
outcome in northern ireland from those
elections makes it clear it can't be put
off and you say it can't be put off what
kind of time frame are we talking about
here well i don't want to jump the gun
because that will lead all the headlines
i think it needs to be dealt with very
responsibly but we've been talking about
we're talking weeks we're talking months
no longer than that uh it must be dealt
with no longer than weeks and i mean
weeks and months you know that can span
a long period of time i i want to i do
not want to escalate uh some of the
tensions that we're seeing i want to
de-escalate them and that means
encouraging the parties to come together
um it was interesting to see the results
across the board
in particular for example the
results of the alliance which very much
campaigned across community divides on
bread and butter local issues i think
that's what the people of northern
ireland want to see focused but the
problem is the stability that allows a
northern ireland executive to get up and
running allows uh the elected
politicians to serve those communities
can't happen until we unlock and fix the
northern ireland protocol
okay um i want to talk to you a bit
about um
the
the potential for border pole as well uh
shin fein of course uh the largest party
they are obviously would have to enter a
power sharing agreement but this is what
the president of uh shin fein uh said uh
mary lou macdonald the president of
champagne she said i believe the
referendum and this is on a united
island i believe the referendum would be
possible within a five-year time frame
but much more importantly i believe the
preparation
needs to start now
what is quite a caveated statement um
but the point i'd make is that if you
look at the results in northern ireland
58
fully of people voted either for parties
who support the union or for parties who
do not support constitutional change and
that is the message from the people of
northern ireland but what is the uk uh
government position on a border pole
well look we don't have an executive um
uh yet
i think the first priority as i said i
mean mindful of that 58
of people in northern ireland who are
not calling um
for that kind of change is to get the
executive up and running get the
stability bring the parties together and
make sure we fix the northern ireland
protocol i think frankly those that is
what the people in northern ireland will
expect right now okay i'm keen to talk
about some of the election results
elsewhere now in england scotland and
wales and just to
get a bit of a picture of what happened
with the conservative party so this is
what happened in england
and i just i'm focusing on the blue
column here the conservatives you lost
339 seats
in england alone
we can go on to scotland
in scotland
you lost 62 seats in scotland hard won
seats in scotland of course under ruth
davidson and in wales you lost 56 seats
in wales as well i mean this is a pretty
disastrous set of results well look um
they're challenging for any government
mid-term
we see these kind of i'm just going to
come in you say that it's challenging
for every any government midterm right
the conservatives have been in power for
12 years yeah when gordon brown was in
power after 12 years in office he lost
291 councillors a lot better than you
and also we all know what happens next i
don't think it's fair to just write this
off as midterms no i'm not i take it
very seriously i know i was out on the
doorstep myself i know the kind of um
issues that were raised and of course
are very varied but all i'd say is um if
you look at kierstama's result in these
local elections yes
they've been difficult for us but uh he
did worse than for example had miliband
in 2012 no cut through really beyond
london we have had a mixed bag of
results there's no sugar coating it but
we've also got areas in the north um
from uh hartlepool barnsley to bolton
and in the south whether it's basildon
um
or thorac where we've done better than
expected so yes it's been difficult set
of results but i think the real story
coming out of all of this and and
politicians were going on all the sunday
shows making their pitch picking all the
different councils where they've done
better exactly so let me let me quote
two very impartial people sir john
curtis uh and professor michael thrasher
who uh said respectively that labour's
performance uh was not making
significant progress uh and thrashers
said that it was not good enough in
making a real deal if you're figuring a
conservative majority so the independent
experts say that i will talk about
latest performance with our next guest
lisa nandy i'm keen to talk about the
conservative performance with you
because as you know it's not just labor
you know it's the lib dems who took a
lot of things
and i'm going to quote an impartial
observer if you like i'll quote the
daily mail
this is uh the daily mail this is what
would success look like at the local
elections for the conservatives and
labor and you can see there in the top
left corner more than 350 losses they're
clocking up as a disaster for the
conservatives yes but look what people
vote in a set of midterm local elections
and what they vote when you choose a
government in general election are two
wholly different things
this is this is what the daily mail
claim that would be a disaster
it for in these local elections for the
conservatives what would be the word you
would use to describe them mixed bag
with a mixed bag challenging yeah you're
a bit complacent here well no i i'm i'm
sorry i'm not i'm pointed to the areas
where we've done better than expected um
even in london which was a very
difficult set of results for us those
areas like the croydon merrily
there's areas like um harlow uh where
we've uh uh uh and and and other areas
where we're actually it has been uneven
uh i i don't think you can take a a
single view other than to say london
under kiestama looks very much a
metropolitan party which has got appeal
in london but not beyond to the rest of
the country
what we're going to be focusing on this
week is what our plans are to
drive up uh the economy protect the cost
of living we're going to be talking
about aggregate reform in the
agricultural sector innovation to create
cheaper healthier food we're going to be
talking about areas where britain has a
real comparative advantage tech
financial services does there need to be
a bit of a research you think then in
the queen speech i don't think it's a
reset look clearly when you have
mid-term local elections there's a lot
of protest votes out there there's a
message that we misheed particularly
about not focusing on westminster but
focusing on them the cost of living
problem uh challenge is going to be
there for the next year do you except
you need to do more on the cost of
living well look we're doing a huge
amount but we've got 22 billion pounds
of support that's going in we've got um
uh uh uh the uh uh the the um extra
money that's going to be coming through
in july with the national insurance
threshold do you except you need to do
more we are doing well that's what i'm
saying in july the national insurance
threshold we raise that's extra money in
people's pockets um uh we've got the
council tax relief uh the energy bills
relief but what i was the point i was
making earlier if you look at the the
kinds of things we're going to be
talking about on the economy in the
weeks ahead um from agriculture to
financial services and tech all areas
with a great comparative advantage we're
the ones the conservative government
with a plan to drive up the job creating
wealth that we need those businesses to
create which also provides the tax
revenue that we're funneling in through
this 22 billion package to help people
who are genuinely finding it hard to
make ends meets labor under kirsten
we're going to spend the less the rest
of the week talking about the curry menu
and the beer um they did or didn't have
up in in durham we're the ones with a
plan to address these cost of living
challenges
um i want to just have a look at how the
conservatives are doing in the south now
sure because obviously you know one of
the big threats for you is the apparent
resurgence of the lib dems in the south
now this is the sky news analysis it's
the average change in vote share
in the south it's the top one there you
can see down 5.9 in the south the lib
dems of course up in the south and i
know you want to talk about labor but
i'm not interested in talking about
labour at this point we can talk about
labor with labor right this is about the
lib dems and the conservatives in the
south your seats in the south yep if we
had swings like this you'd lose your
seat the next election look it's going
to be a tough fight for me in my seat um
although actually i'll just point out in
the council we still have more seats
than the liberal democrats on that
council what you're seeing here and the
lib dems have often done it history
shows they're a repository for some
protests vote midterm and although you
don't want to talk about labour that's
precisely because labour are doing so
poorly in the rest of england outside
london but what people want us to see is
get focused on those things that i
talked about um and that's why the plans
that we're talking about to drive up uh
innovation uh in the tech the
agricultural sector and financial
services doesn't just create the
well-paid jobs of the future it creates
the tax revenue so that those that are
really feeling the pinch we can provide
that extra support we're the ones with
the plan and that's what we're going to
be talking about do you think that might
be a few weeks focusing on the red wall
you've taken your eye
of what's happening in your blue wall in
traditional southern conservative
heartlands like your own i've always
said it's a balance you've got to knit
an alliance between the aspirational
working and middle classes but that's
what we're focused on and that's why
we're the ones as i said with the plan
for the cost of living uh whether it's
the
universal credit taper um you've spoken
about this we have but we're the ones
with the plan we're going to be talking
about that this week whereas i think
you're going to find keir starmark
wrapped up in beergate and durham and
the double standards on the labour party
yeah i'm going to we're getting off that
i'm going to ask you about because i
think you do want to talk about it which
is what i do you've referenced it twice
because it's the contrast so
do you think that kirsten needs to
resign now that he's being investigated
by the police which is what he said
boris johnson of course and rishi soon
actually sophie it's the ranked double
standards that drives people crazy he
needs to
fess up and answer all of the um holes
in the account that he gave of that beer
and curry
event in durham but frankly i'm not
focused on that and that's why i wanted
to draw the contrast what we're focused
on what this government is focused on is
the measures we're taking on the economy
on tech on the agricultural sector our
farmers brilliant innovation to be done
there financial services to drive up the
well-paid jobs of the future but also
and this is where only the conservatives
offer a plan for a dynamic economy that
doesn't just create the development you
need to tax revenue
people at this difficulties
position i'm not getting into all that
because frankly i'll tell you the thing
i heard on the doorstep loud and clear
they want politicians focused on their
issues okay not westminster but what i
would say about it is kirsten looks like
i'm afraid someone who's gauged in
complete hypocrisy complete double
standards and i don't think he's going
to get past that until he gives a proper
account of what happened in durham okay
i mean labour had said that they have
explained what happened in durham and
they said that they're very very
confident that they unlike the prime
minister they won't be found to have
broken the law but as you say let's talk
about other issues that people are uh
interested about now i spoke to david
simmons the conservative mp uh earlier
this week he said the number one issue
on the doorstep was partygate and the
prime minister's conduct and he spoke
about how frustrated he was that the
actions of one individual were coming up
and the councillors had been lost as a
result
and he said that frankly you know he's
gonna be listening to what the prime
minister says and working out whether or
not he has confidence in his leadership
going forward how worried are you that
there will be conservative mps thinking
look hang on a minute we might be
putting in those letters and no
confidence well i don't think so i mean
look i respect all of um
my colleagues and then they you know
they make their points and i also feel
for the conservative candidates that
lost their seats um or didn't win their
seats i had one who missed out by just
12 votes which is
very frustrating i feel full of them but
the reality is i think coming through
these local elections there was no cut
through for labour and kier stammer and
what we've got to do as a team then i
get it but what we've got to do as a
team from our councils our mps to our
government and with the leadership of
the pm is get focused on those bread and
butter issues people care about and
that's why don't you think though sorry
that's why i come back to what we're
going to be talking about over the next
month how to drive up the well-paid jobs
of the future but also critically if
you've got a dynamic economy to pay for
the tax revenue that's going to provide
the support for people with the cost of
living that's the crucial issue we're
talking about it none of the other
parties are talking about it i just
wonder if you know people like david
simmons listening to your interview
saying that oh yeah these results were a
mixed bag they're going to think the
people in cabinet just don't get it
they're not complacent look i i seen it
for myself we have difficult results in
elm bridge uh in the home counties they
were but i also think we need to uh be
sober about this we need to recognize
that midterm elections are difficult uh
and and critically that the labour party
has had very little cut through outside
london so so there's a job to do but
that job is not engaged in naval gazing
in westminster it's about addressing the
policy platform of everything we're
doing on the economy on jobs and on the
cost of living and that's what you're
going to hear that's what the government
is going to be setting out in the weeks
ahead is boris johnson still
an asset
electorally for the conservative i'm
confident that he can and will win the
next election but that's not something
that you just assert you've got to back
it up and that's why we come back to the
measures that we're going to be talking
about on the economy also on the nhs um
on social care um and but critically the
relief that only the conservatives with
a dynamic economy can provide people who
are feeling the pinch of the cost of
living you won't get that with the
others so we'll hear
boris johnson will lead the conservative
party into the next election then yes